which youtuber makes the most amount of
money I think about it for just a second
I know I know you're all thinking me no
but no not me and I know the next
thought is pudy pie right everyone knows
booty pies you G's playing video games
and if I get it right beauty beauty as
in pew pew the point is it's not him
either yeah you know who it is it is a
woman an anonymous woman up until now at
least by the name of DC toy collector
what does she do on the youtubes she
unboxes children's disney toys that's it
yeah let's take a look hey guys
Disney collector here and today we're
going to have some fun with sparkling
play-doh and Disney Princess since we
have here six different colors we're
going to be making six different sparkly
dresses one for each of this princess
first one to get a sparkling dress it's
gonna be bow so let's remove the glitter
glider dress leave it aside and start
working on the new dress alright so that
is literally all she does she has dozens
and dozens of videos unboxing Disney
toys she has a sort of angelic voice I
suppose guess how much she's making on
YouTube a year five million dollars
which is just above what your paw
yeah total just teeny right above nerd
alert just right not even gonna lie not
even gonna lie oh yeah so she's making
an incredible amount of money now what I
thought was interesting that's just
interesting in and of itself but now it
has come out that she actually is a porn
star we've got an image of her her name
is sandy summers and she went through
incredible lengths to not have her real
identity revealed because obviously
she's reviewing these toys that her
children's toys so we assume that it's a
lot of children that are watching the
videos she also disables the comments on
her videos by the way which I'm guessing
she does intentionally so that people
that might want to be just saying awful
dirty perverted [ __ ] if kids are going
to the video they don't have to see that
stuff so she's really done every
precaution that she could possibly
do to keep this thing on the up-and-up
but she got outed and uh they figured
out because of a scar and some other
stuff
who cares is what I would further we can
talk about the YouTube angle first but
who cares someone's in the sex work
business they're also making videos on
YouTube who cares
we love demonizing people who are in sex
work industry uh who have ever posed
nude in their lives anyone who's been a
victim of revenge porn
we love victimizing them it's ridiculous
and so I don't care but I know that
they're probably a lot of mothers out
there who watch these videos who care so
I think it makes sense that she's making
a lot of money these unboxing videos are
genius and I'm angry at myself for not
thinking about it first can you explain
a little bit about why you think they're
genius because I watched a couple of
them in preparations and they're so
idiotic but there is something as I said
angelic about it was the same as in but
what what do you think genius so it
seems ridiculous to you cuz you're not
interested in the product but for people
who are considering purchasing the
product watching these videos give you a
better sense of what you're gonna get
okay are you going to get your money's
worth so some people do this with
technology let's say they buy a new
phone and then they unbox it and they
show you all the different like gadgets
that it comes with and it just makes
sense to me because you want to know
what you're paying for a lot of people
shop online so I mean I like to buy
clothing online and I would love it if
some of the retailers that I buy from
put out some videos like unboxing it so
I know what I'm gonna expect when I get
into the mail right so just so you know
the video had 209 million views 209
million views watching a girl unbox
Disney toys I get all of Anna's reasons
there but what do you make of the
unboxing thing so I've watched her
channel before you told me to watch it
yeah and I had I was interested in who
she was - she made it kind of a mystique
like who is this lady is this other
channel her husband blah blah blah
I think it's cool I mean when you gave
me the story I didn't I didn't think the
story was you know oh she used to be a
porn star that the story was look at
this amazing look how well this is doing
and you know I think it's popular
because it's hitting a few different
points like one there's the unboxing
thing where you see something new and
you get that like that
that hits pleasure centers and then
there's also playing with toys which is
also fun I like Disney I have a
childlike sense of wonder that was the
most oddest thing I've ever heard you
say I have a childlike sense of wonder I
do gee Kim um but these alright so I'm
with you on all that but you think
there's a weird danger in fetishizing
stuff you know I mean just this idea I
get it for the clothes thing it kind of
makes sense because if there was a girl
who you trusted and she was like and
this feels right and we have similar
body but just this idea of with the tip
with all the phones and everything that
it's just all about stuff like we're
putting on welcome America I mean that's
capitalism we're obsessed with stuff I'm
obsessed with stuff I'm a female
addicted to retail it is what it is um
so is it dangerous I guess yeah
especially considering credit card debt
and all that but overall I'm 100% giving
her a pass do you boo I'm so happy she's
making this kind of money and I'm angry
at myself for not being smart enough to
think about it right well here's the
deal like this is a very simple concept
here's a toy look at the toy wow it's
really when you look at more you know
complicated topics like existential
issues deep philosophical worries it's
harder to one tag and title that to get
people who are interested in this
abstract concept it's a toy there's the
toy easy right so it's sort of marketing
101 all right well I'm gonna end this
with I'm gonna put you guys both on the
spot so I'm glad we didn't focus on the
porn aspect of this cuz I think it
really is irrelevant whether she's
whatever she does in her personal life I
don't really don't think it matters do
you guys ever fear that something you've
done in your past could affect your
future because that this thing could
come back to haunt her now um I am
overly cautious when it comes to certain
things so I've obviously said
controversial things on the show and I
take full ownership of them and when I'm
wrong I'll take ownership of that as
well in terms of like nude pictures or
videos I have a really strict policy
against ever taking or doing any of them
so I have nothing to worry about I'm
fine a woman with nothing to fear Kim I
haven't taken any like naughty pictures
either at least I mean yeah and I
haven't done it know that we're not a
tribe
alls I'm saying is you can't trace it to
me so don't even try